what's an anime that was funny purely
because it was just
so [ __ ] awful and like i mean there's
a lot
that's my entire career i'm just
watching bad anime and laughing at it
when i watched king's game for the first
time i [ __ ] lost it i couldn't stop
laughing at how [ __ ] is happening oh
yeah
king's game was bad and then there was
the dub
which just made it i didn't watch the
devil it's not
bad i felt so bad because it was obvious
that like you know it wasn't on their
priority
yeah it was it was rough dude it was
rough
that's a real shame as well because like
when i heard that the king's game anime
was like
[ __ ] horrible i was like oh man i
kind of like the manga though so it's
like
really a shame that the anime just like
completely [ __ ] it i can't remember i
only watched two episodes before i was
like i've seen enough yeah
i i i was just like [ __ ] dude this is
[ __ ] awful
i think the scene i burst out on that i
burst out laughing at was uh
i think there was a challenge where the
guy had to sleep with
the girl or something like that and and
and uh it it's the girl is like the
main guy's girlfriend or crush i can't
remember what it was
but so so it's his best friend who has
to sleep with this girl
who is the main character's girlfriend
i'm just going to say girlfriend now
um and so he doesn't want to do it he
doesn't want to
betray his bro like that so the main
character is trying to [ __ ] argue
with this guy to sleep with his
girlfriend
and so he refuses so what he does his
solution is to [ __ ] deck the guy in
the face
until he's unconscious and then he go he
turns to his girlfriend in the dub and
just
do it while he's unconscious please and
i'm just like
oh my god so you're just so bad
i mean that's that's basically what
happens
it's it's [ __ ] awful but the way
the way the anime played it so seriously
contrasted to how awful the situation
goes and how
how it was being portrayed was just like
the juxtaposition just made me [ __ ]
laugh
man like it's like obviously rape isn't
a joke and everything like that
but this anime was so awful that you
couldn't help but laugh that's what i
was trying to say
how about you jerry any anime you think
of the topic god i mean like
i mean i've been meaning to like make a
series on my channel where i do exactly
that where i just take the worst anime
and just laugh at it um like i don't
know a lot of the like the most horrible
ones are like
obviously the ones that no one's ever
[ __ ] hurt
so uh like i don't know what's the
famous one like
like skill to heaven is a famous one
master destruction is a famous one
you ever seen any of those no you ever
seen those i haven't i still haven't
seen miles of destruction oh mars is
destroying delta heaven sounds familiar
i don't know why yeah tank uh
yeah skelter it's like one of the worst
rated anime basically aiken's another
one that's
not the worst oh no i can oh [ __ ]
akin is so bad oh my god i love it
but yeah i've been meaning to make
[ __ ] some videos on them all but like
those ones make sense though right
because it's like of course no one knows
them
they're [ __ ] horrible yeah right but
i'm trying to think like what's like a
well-known anime
that's bad that is like horrible like
it's because it's well known because
it's bad because like the only one i can
think of
is this anime called ghazi's wing which
is
like i would say that's less famous and
more
infamous yeah i'd say like the most
other infamous one is probably the ghost
stories dub
maybe yeah i mean if we're gonna bring
up ghost stories
it means i'll still talk about it okay
the ghost story is dubbed
i mean it was [ __ ] legendary my
favorite [ __ ] dog
i'm never gonna get anything like that
ever again we never will because
do you know the story behind how that's
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i know a lot
about it why don't you explain it for
people who
don't know basically ghost stories is a
i okay what is the actual plot of the
show
kids go into an abandoned school
building fine ghost trains
resolve isn't it just their school
building it's like there's just ghosts
and they have to use
it's like an abandoned side of the
building right there's like the main
building and then there's
yeah they basically have to get rid of
ghosts yeah yeah basically basically
it's the story doesn't matter what
matters is the dub
as it's considered one of the best or
the best
worst dub of all time or the worst best
dub of all time yeah it's like
because because online it seems to be
like people can't agree if it's
like good or bad yeah i don't know it's
it's like it's funny
it's the room of anime yeah yeah so
basically what happened is
this this was a show that sold
so poorly when it when it was aired in
japan
that when they sold the licenses they
just basically told the licenses
do whatever you want with this show to
make it sell
like we don't care you have all creative
you're you have all creative control
and so basically they just [ __ ] posted
in the dub
it's often like seen as the very first
abridged series because it's
basically what happens if you if a bunch
of official doubles just
basically found up and abridged the show
and [ __ ] about
um and it's one of the most infamous
like dubs that has ever been released
like the one the father kills me every
time he's like the little
the younger brother yeah and his entire
life time he's just going
like everything like his mouth's moving
but the dog is just like i'm gonna make
him cry
every line there's a really good video
uh about it by uh cartoon type i can't
remember if it did sell badly or not i
know that's the common thing but i swear
they there was some point where that
actually wasn't the case
right and it did do well um i can't
remember exactly the story but again
yeah cartoon cypher did a
really great like 30 minute video about
this whole dub um they spoke to a ton of
sources it's really good video
um it's just a really unique dub and
also because of how they recorded it
normally when you record anime
uh whoever goes in first is like the
first to record so yeah
basically they all wanted to go in first
yeah so they could like start the improv
scene right
so everyone at the playoff have went
first so they were all trying to get in
first it was just interesting because
when you're watching it you know that
you're like i wonder who started like
what this scene yeah because even if
they spoke first doesn't mean they were
the one who recorded first yeah so it's
fun to try and figure out
i wonder who [ __ ] started this [ __ ]
[ __ ] joke basically
and it's just such a fun dub i don't
know if you guys watched it at all
oh yeah i've seen it all yeah yeah i've
seen it all yeah it's so fun i really
wish that we could
get something again but we're never
gonna get anything yeah yeah it's it's
it's different times it's different
times now i i'm sure some of the jokes
that were setting up probably
would not be able to have like you
couldn't get away with in this day and
age
but it's just such like a time stamp for
that time period
and it's just basically all improv as
well which is which is
kind of kind of funny how some like some
of the jokes i thought were very good
and the fact that it wasn't it wasn't
scripted at all and it was just all
improv i'm just like
man this this this i still think it's
funny to this oh yeah yeah
even though it might be slightly you
know not politically correct it's
definitely not politically correct like
the rabbit scene yeah he died i was so
sad that i would never hear that voice
again his laugh
his funny little requests touch me
his reprimands touch me harder oh yeah
it's
it's it's uh wait what was the joke
about that rabbit where like the dad
leaves or something
no no it was like the yeah i can't get
with you
it's not because you're a rabbit it's
because you're black oh my god
do you remember that one oh my god
and then the rabbit like in the in the
flashback the rabbit is like talking in
the flashback it's like touch me harder
oh yeah
right right yeah you'd never get away
with that now yeah
yeah i i think it's also back then like
there was money in it but the money
level scale was like very different
oh yeah yeah and i think a lot of the
dubbing is focused more on the the big
shows